ciao ragazzi bentornati una puntata di
cucina buttata oggi stiamo per fare una
delle cose che io non sapevo se
potessero fare è appena scoperto che
effettivamente alcune persone praticano
questa roba qui sono impazzito tra i
commenti che abbiamo ricevuto ce n'era
una in particolare che ha attirato la
nostra attenzione
ossia fare la pizza in padella padella
iniziamente ho pensato ma che dice
questo qui magari un esperimento strano
che symbol si potrebbe fare interessante
da vicino ho scoperto che effettivamente
la pizza in padella viene fatta anche in
alcuni ristoranti in cui vado a mangiare
non farò una pizza
ho deciso di fare delle pizzettine se
non ne sono molto più sfiziose molto più
semplice molto più easy secondo me anche
più veloci e in aumento non avevo idea
di come comportarci siamo andati su
internet e gianmarco ha trovato una
ricetta che vi linkiamo qui sotto e che
cercheremo di riprodurre addirittura
dicono che sia così facile e veloce da
essere pronta in 15 minuti che abbiamo
letto pixel 15 minuti non abbiamo non
potuto non cercare di farla quindi
partiamo subito con gli ingredienti una
padella che finalmente posseggo 150 g di
farina dei pelati bocconcini di
mozzarella fiordilatte basilico
che schifo ma lasciano tutto motore rich
delizioso vada a casa potrebbe esserne
rosa super allergica ultimo video 8
grammi di lievito per pizze torte salate
e piadine 4 grammi 4 g 25 grammi di sale
rigorosamente bianco è ancora vietato e
vai rumore 90 grammi d'acqua o un
cucchiaino d'olio
iniziamo subito con procedimento vediamo
quanto riusciamo a essere velocità in
alt mancano ingrediente
ma prima di tutto sgocciolate la
mozzarella e tagliatela a pezzettini che
era quello che volevo fare
prima di tutto la mozzarella budino
esatta per me è una puntualità della
mela volgarità entrare nel bagno dopo
che ci sei stato tu e trovi la finestra
aperta e non basta
lo faccio per dare già regate mi porta
che si entra c è più tornato il mittente
del vaglio vuol dire basta basta basta
la cia da melo però devono metterlo via
tagliamo le forbici però dai perché no
io non è niente alte gretel asciugata
tutta a quelle mozzarelle la baby di una
vita non ho mangiato una mozzarella
fiordilatte abbastanza inutile facciamo
per finta pelle tegame anti cessioni si
ma non ho neanche mangiata ma
eccezionale che non ebrei polizia perché
così si secca un pochino presenta sei
soddisfatto quando taglia mozzarella ma
c'era della soddisfazione
allora andiamo lì pasqua quando avevo
l'impatt resto l'acqua il sale a 4
grammi ma si scusi sta facendo così a
occhio lo sportello cui il grembiule i
ragazzi la quantità con i numeri
le portate di quel che la carta perché
dio che lo vado a prendere subito non ci
crede nel ritorno di questore festa di
morte che schifo no non lo posso mettere
blu passati morte è così tanto in
putrefazione che il proprietario che si
allargano io ero con i poteri
dell'oltretomba e tutto ciò mai non ci
credono molto meglio
sono tornato a respirare e al grembiule
[Applauso]
l'impatto suppongo sia giusto è troppo
piccolo riesco maneggiarlo mila della
farina un un jeans impostare dello
sportello lo devi sempre questo rubino e
piccoli troppo piccola non è già in
poche bello impasta mi per bene il
sunderland è già fatta se ora devi
lasciare un secondo a riposare parole
con secondo il tempo duro crollare
rivelati ma se tutto essere qui aspetta
di euro rimetto da mamma mi sarà
visionata che non ha fatta visionava
alla vita di quelle brutte mi potete
fermare più come si dice anarchico un
personaggio anarchico si deve sempre
creare le sue regole ci sono delle
regole lui se ne creerà mai e che lo
vedi più goccio d'olio un pizzico di
sale
enrico appoggiato sempre al frigo mi
ricordo così fire i cadaveri
suppongo che la spesa in basso la
maltratta è già d'accordo se vuoi te lo
leggo al collo perché la cui guido
queste persone hanno l'apparenza
è il boot in via piave era esile a casa
staranno impazzendo
ma perché non si stende ecco bravo
braccia in aria
si vabbè sulla lampadina ogni ormai ero
mamma mia mi chiedo se fortissimo sì ma
è passata un centimetro due volte da
quella la vedi il corto circuito per
lenza mi prendete un coppapasta piccolo
mamma mia lo zombie the walking dead che
se quello che ci serve
direi di passare al coppa vasta questo
qui ora lo rimpasti amo scusate ma a
contestare il fuoco schiacciate il
centro con un dito perché così il
condimento national ogni tanto mi
stupisci pensi che io sia un celenterato
cioè tu pensi che tuo fratello abbia
proprio un neurone solitario ma quindi
si può c'è solo il lato sotto panneggi
come non giri la pizza margherita del
forno a legna come però questa è una
padella con un forno è capito che dico
il forno è caldo tutto ma calore si
trasmette in tutto quanto il corpo nel
rigoletto due giorni in libri storia
perché stiamo dando i numeri magari se
metto la salsa devi lasciare il bordo
libero sostanzialmente lo sai che in
un'altra vita faceva il pizzaiolo e
rifaceva lo chef aaa noti più non facevi
lo chef è in realtà voi non lo potete
sentire ragazzi ma fa un autore assurdo
del cristo in una parola italia ci sente
su basilico il profumo del pomodoro
unito al niente assoluto dai guarda lo
posso dire che sono un po this abituato
al fatto che vengono delle ricette per
la cultura
quando il puzzle e allora parole il
basilico in italia il simbolo
dell'italia anche nei colori della
bandiera e quant'altro poco grande
fiamma dolce cinque minuti esatti scopri
metti la mozzarella ricopri 23 minuti e
nando mi sembra fantascienza per quanto
mi riguarda ma vogliamo farne altre
si no perché queste tele magni proprio
dura dietro l'altra lui dire tu non ha
messo il timer
il disco alla 105 milioni fermo non ne
fai una giusta no no non c'è una ricetta
dove fai tutto perfetto
non lo conosco facebook bacon però gli
ingredienti non erano tutti me lo
ricordo carbonara verranno accesi no
quella romana ma ti stanno già vinto lo
so non essere una rischio ma me ne frega
una mia è un pezzetti sempre mangiato
quando mia madre faceva l'impasto è
allungata non ti piace è quella di
possono prova che ho paura che questo
cioè delle stranezze un appello alla
nazione è più strano uno che mangia un
impasto della pizza crudo o io che mi fa
schifo chat e le stranezze che vede il
parmigiano e viene da trattato di veri
del campione del tu instagram
grazie in un appena fatto pubblicità si
opera queste pubblicità di gianmarco e
scrivete che bel profilo
però devi mettere una foto di te di
profilo social lato può combattere le
tue insicurezze
da qui guarda qui ecco questa è la
proprio mettere su instagram è brutta
bruttissima fai un profilo però in mezzo
tipo ma guardano entrato con un accenno
mezzana cucina la luce di eventi che
prevedono gian marco martino lo scrivo
sotto guglielmo qui che bel profilo
mozzarella se si sono leggermente fiato
ok io posso dire che trovo la padella
stupenda o anche le pentole dove dentro
stanno le zuppe to aggiunge aggiunge
aggiungi tipo piton ultimi aggiunge
aggiungere mesco il match con esko ti
fai giupponi vogliamo fare una buona
zuppa noi vogliamo fare la pozione
polisucco amici ed era questo e poi ce
li mette i capelli dentro più che altro
fai schifo ma genitore mesmerico incubo
finito sono stupende non è per niente
bruciato mascia delle mani tipo di
batteri non mi fate arrabbiare ma
andiamo e così siamo giunti al momento
dell'assaggio prima di farlo ricordate
che se mi ha divertito questo video se
vi è piaciuto se è tornato utile di
metterci un bel pollice in su perillo e
soprattutto di scrivere questo canale
fateci come sempre sapere quali sono i
vostri commenti visto che come potete
vedere finiscono a volte nelle nostre
tavole purtroppo nei nostri stomaci e
successivamente nei nostri cessi che
diretta radio maggio e assaggiare oltre
alle partite però qui
forme via lo stop non riesco a tenerlo
in mano ma non ne prendo un'altra no no
no no questo secondo devo mettere un
boccone le gabine vedere la sua niente
male
una terza scelta se l'amore di uno ti si
sfalda invece parte mia di fa consorelle
invece tutto un buco nero
non propongo resto la sapori nella sua
globalità a verso la domanda è l'ultimo
boccone la facciamo colazione non si può
l'hardware sexy ok con i gusti voto
gianni anzi credo che le fregate mio io
mi astengo lo diresti a settimana muto
basta per mangiare lo so ma io non ho io
sono un estro e la devo fare il mio ex
sulla scheda elettorale allora detto
turno e ci può cote registi cibo che
poté anch'io ho sempre allora ti voto
uno smacco forza ma no no no no
milano la verità e zucchero può fregare
unico e ti volevo portare qui no no no
no io non la mangiarotti per mangiare no
no si mangia forza guglielmo io non ho
problemi a mangiarle mai mangiate la
sola desideri e ora desidero ma sono
stato al gioco e mi farò un quiz per
vedere chi prenderà pasta pizza no ma ti
stai girando il gioco
eccolo ma pur di partita genio a vedere
la bellezza miss bevuto il pomodoro che
mister emo fidato di nuovo nelle narici
basilico quale possono video su questo
canale atonica passano dodici numeri e
un altro di cucina al prossimo video
quindi martedì prossimo con un blog